[Musique]
qumrân
c'est ici
là où la mer morte prend sa source dans
l'un des points les plus bas du monde
que des prêtres du temple de jérusalem
vint s'installer une centaine d'années
avant l'ère vulgaire coupé du monde de
ses tracas de sa politique
il voulait y vivre un judaïsme
authentique bercé d'orthodoxie et de
mystique
on les appelait les esséniens
tantôt rejetée tantôt adulé
ils n'ont cessé sur près de 150 ans de
faire des émules et sous le règne
d'hérode
ils eurent une relation privilégiée avec
le temple et ses prêtres en l'an 60 8
quand les romains détruire le temple de
jérusalem ils massacrent est également
les habitants de qumrân aujourd'hui deux
mille ans après ces événements le parc
archéologique de cobral dépens de
l'autorité des antiquités de l'état
d'israël c'est là qu'ont été découverts
ces 70 dernières années plus d'un
milliers de manuscrits écrits sur des
parchemins et du papyrus et cachés dans
onze grottes ou car ce sont les fameux
manuscrits de la mer morte
ils comprennent des exemplaires de
l'ancien testament des commentaires sur
la bible et la loi juive des textes
mystiques et liturgique des codes et des
règlements de la communauté de cobral
[Musique]
les manuscrits de qumrân sont la plus
importante découverte archéologique de
ces 70 dernières années car c'est une
source de témoignages extraordinairement
riche sur une époque mais ces manuscrits
ne sont rien à côté des trésors qui se
cache sous le sol de cobral
[Musique]
désert de judée 4 heures du matin
aujourd'hui démarre la fouille qui
devrait permettre de découvrir le trésor
caché de wadi aquitains et ainsi mettre
un terme à une chasse au trésor qui aura
duré plus de 50 ans et au cours de
laquelle se seront affrontés les plus
célèbre archéologue
[Musique]
l'union
tout commence en 1952 lorsque des
archéologues français
on rit de contention et ernest marie
lapérouse has de l'équipe du père de vos
découvre des rouleaux dans une grotte à
quatre kilomètres de qumran devions
aller explorer pendant que le père de
vos fougue et leur le dans le qui
rebaptise même et les derniers jours il
y avait arquois tout à fait au nord
n'est pas nettoyée et on l'a commencée
elle nettoyer et là on a découvert deux
masses verdâtre d'une part de l'autre
alors on a immédiatement oui un message
quand le père de veau et envoyé son
meilleur pour tous m il a soigneusement
nettoyés et s'est avéré que c'était 2-2
roubaud apparemment cuivre le bruit a
couru tout de suite dans le camp des
doi que j'avais trouvé deux colonnes en
or ça c'est pareil c'est tout ça que
secret les légendes mais en fait c'était
pour mon plus intéressant encore si
c'est vite fait des colonnes en or parce
que c'est celle au prix va être
entièrement inscrit en lettres
hébraïques et grecs ont été elles de se
constituer un seul document
une fois une fois déroulé aura fait il
reste plus beaucoup de cuir est plus
glauque site
donc c'est très cassant ne peut plus se
dérouler comme le cuivre est oxydé il
faudra attendre trois ans avant de
trouver le moyen qui permettra de
l'ouvrir et de révéler au monde
son secret aux minéraux le il a fallu
qu'un laboratoire de birmingham il le
découpe en tranches puis posées les unes
à côté des autres
et il ya eu un premier les chiffrements
qui a été fait par joseph musique
[Musique]
on y décrit en hébreu ancien mais les
deux grecs et de cryptogrammes un trésor
répartis dans 64 cash est différente
il y aurait des objets d'or et d'argent
des pièces de monnaie mais aussi et
surtout des vêtements et objets sacrés
le détail de leurs descriptions évoque
les ustensiles en or et les tenues du
service du temple de jérusalem leurs
rouleaux de cuivre trouvait à qumrân
serait-il la clé du trésor du temple
le texte qui est un aspect c'est une
liste une liste de wind trésor sous ça
ne cesse de basse le nord et qui sont
déposés dans des endroits avec des les
repères et à battre est de les retrouver
le texte du rouleau se termine en
précisant qu'une copie en a été faite
ainsi qu'un autre rouleau qui fournit
les indications et l'inventaire pièce
par pièce des objets cachés
mais surtout qui donne les mesures
permettant de retrouver les cachettes
ces rouleaux aurait été enfouis dans un
tunnel appelé la chambre secrète est
situé près d'un cimetière dans la région
de wadi acquis par le docteur guéri
colette professeur de théologie aux
états unis a consacré sa vie à la
recherche de cette chambre secrète en
1993 sa rencontre avec michel calvo un
avocat français passionné par le temple
de jérusalem va donner une nouvelle
dimension à cette quête est ce que c'est
sérieux cette histoire du rouleau de
cuivre le permis ligue qui a publié la
première traduction du rouleau de cuivre
a estimé qu'il s'agissait d'une
tradition populaire juive relative un
trésor fictifs
quant à nous comme d'autres archéologues
nous pensons que c'est une histoire très
sérieuse pourquoi n'avoir pas utilisé un
parchemin ont un papyrus comme les
autres manuscrits découvert la cobra et
l'avoir caché dans une cave avec toute
l'industrie de l'époque biblique michel
caro s'est donc rendu à paris pour
interroger le professeur henry de
contention qui est découvert leurs
rouleaux de cuivre
pouvez vous nous dire s'il s'agit d'un
folklore juif comme le père milite l'a
dit oudin vrais trésors cachés alors le
joseph munich à pense trouver ce texte n
1110 nerfs il a pensé que peut-être un
texte football c'est quand même étonnant
qu'on ait ça donnait tellement mal pour
texte folklorique
vraisemblablement il s'agit d'un vrai
trésor à condition qu'on ne tombe pas
d'attribution
le professeur ernest marie l'apéro zaz
est historien et archéologue
il est considéré en france comme l'un
des meilleurs spécialistes sur les
rouleaux de la mer morte et a déjà
publié plusieurs livres et articles sur
le sujet lui non plus ne croient pas
dans la théorie du permis qu en réalité
d'ailleurs combien regretté que dans
notre domaine des études du projet lyon
ancien il n'y a très peu d'historiens et
d'archéologues de métier la bleue par
jean ou des théologiens ou des
philologues et le viol au log
c'est un bon traducteur mais il n'est
pas fonctionnement doué pour le
commentaire de l'historien
les progrès de la technologie vont
permettre de reprendre l'interprétation
du texte du rouleau depuis
et parce qu'il ya une dizaine d'années
lolo a été plus au sortir de deux ans
lundi pour être nettoyée par deux
laboratoires d'edf qui a la pudeur
nettoyer parce qu il venait d oxyde qui
sont mes deux nouveaux qui a pu les
reconsolider et une nouvelle lecture a
pu être faite par une mutuelle de
l'école biblique de jérusalem
c'est en face des murailles de jérusalem
avec dans son jardin un caveau funéraire
que certains pensent être le tombeau des
rois d'israël que se trouve l'école
biblique de jérusalem un couvent
dominicain surtout connu pour ses
sous-sols une énorme bibliothèque bâti
sur deux étages et renfermant plus de
140 mille livres et manuscrits depuis
120 ans la basilique saint-etienne
puisque c'est son nom conserve tout ce
qui a pu être écrit sur la bible et les
langues sémitiques on y trouve aussi les
rapports sur les fouilles archéologiques
entreprises par l'école biblique
c'est dans le cadre de ces fouilles qui
ont été découverts nombreux des rouleaux
de la mer morte et notamment les fameux
rouleaux de cuivre qui nous intéresse
est dans la bibliothèque sont conservés
les traductions effectué par les prêtres
enseignants de l'école sur les étagères
à côté de différents exemplaire du
talmud sont posés les traductions du
père puech qui a retraduit rouleaux de
cuir
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ya de grandes différences
entre la traduction que le permis dit
café est la vôtre
je pense qu une intonation était
nécessaire de la mesure où et des f a dû
restaurer le rouleau et donc du coup il
a fait des nouvelles photographies on a
progressé beaucoup avait des choses qui
avaient été oubliés des nouvelles de
nouveaux joints on a un texte un peu
plus complète que le fait d'avoir
demandé à edf de me faire ce qu'il
m'avait demandé de faire un relevé
vous avez vu la mer j'ai fait le relevé
les jeunes a réuni pour faire se relever
il me faut une photo bien sûr comme tout
et il était pour objet ni impossible
j'ai dit faites moi un instant pas un
moulage manic-1 possible c'est trop
fragile alors on a fait un montage
numérique mais qui l'amène qui ne valent
n'a pas été satisfaisant à mon point de
vue donc on a fait un moulage et puis de
moulage en moulage de pâtir segment on a
fait un double en galvanoplastie qui m'a
permis de faire un dessin est comme ça
de retrouver comme quand on découvre la
dimension exacte des lacunes et donc et
pour comprendre et pour restaurer les
passages c'était absolument
indispensable
vous pouvez vous nous dire ce que vous
avez apporté avec votre traduction en
plus de ses qualités cet or le permis vu
le moulage j'ai pu
on dirait avoir à plat non pas en
dimension complexe d'animation exact de
lacunes et donc du coup de pouvoir
restaurer ou qu'on peut proposer vue le
sens de la phrase la teneur de vos
positions qu'ils automate est impossible
et ça c'est très pénible
si vous voulez quand on regarde le
dessin saïda et notre être réduit ici
mais une vision d'ensemble des trois
feuilles du rouleau la première feuille
il résister à la deuxième et les rives
et s'était cassé tout ça qu'on avait
fait un deuxième roman la troisième
feuille le début à la fin vous avez de
différentes cassure est mis à plat on a
une vision exacte des dimensions qui
manque est de ceux qui pour préserver
sinon on ne voit pas très bien mais on
n'arrive pas à saisir
qu'est ce qui manque qu'est-ce qu'on a
retrouvée c'est le fait d'avoir été
obligé de dessiner m'a obligé de
ralentir très près comment le graveur
allègre avait cessé ses lettres et j'ai
appris des choses
c'est là une difficulté et comme tout
soutient que les mots ne sont pas
séparés passé parce que c'est un petit
peu plus difficile mais
c'est l'art de l'épée graphiste pour en
savoir plus sur le trésor du temple de
jérusalem et la communauté des esséniens
de cobral michel qu'elle vous retourne à
jérusalem plus exactement dans le
quartier juif de la vieille ville pour y
rencontrer le rabbin david cohen un
cabas liste qui a la particularité
d'être un descendant direct du grand
prêtre san roque fondateur de la
communauté de qumrân le rabbin david
cohen dirige une niche yvette mekhout
baline une école talmudique où les
élèves qui sont déjà des rabbins
confirmés ou des scribes vient étudier
les secrets de la kabbale la mystique
juive généralement enseigné dans le
secret de père en fils depuis des
générations
est-ce que c'est sérieux cette histoire
du rouleau de cuir je pense que tout à
fait sérieux parce que nous savons
pertinemment que lorsqu'ils ont voulu
garder des choses de valeur
il est clair qu'il fallait craindre un
emplacement où personne ne se doutait
que la sambre l'on pourrait les trouver
la kabbale n'en parle pas beaucoup mais
n'en fait que des allusions et la même
manière que nous savons que des choses
sont arrivés à rome et il ya eu des gens
qui l'ont vu mais qui n'ont pas survécu
à cela il est clair la cavale dis que tu
as fait que tombent entre les mains de
nos ennemis
c'est que ce qui paraît de l'apparence
mais que les vrais objets ont été
enfouis sous la terre et donc il
semblerait que des objets du temple ont
subi le même sort
c'est pour ça que c'est vrai qu'au
vatican il y aurait des choses mais
peut-être que le vrai objet serait le
message du rouleau de cuivre est donc à
prendre au sérieux
mais pour retrouver son trésor galerie
colette et michel calvo devront d'abord
identifier le site de waziers kippa ou
est censé se trouver la chambre secrète
renfermant le deuxième rouleau donnant
toutes les indications sur l'emplacement
des cachettes de 6,6 points
très vite ils vont découvrir que wodié
qui parle n'est autre que la montagne
surplombant le site de qumrân
4h50 faut des kippas podium car quand ce
cadre qu'a donc je pense tout simplement
choisi cet emplacement
parce que vraiment personne n'aurait
jamais pu imaginer que cet endroit là se
seraient cachés mais voulant descendre
et c'est quand même la possibilité à la
à ce que au moment opportun où le ciel
de déciderez on pourrait retrouver cela
ils ont juste du crif qui peut tenir
très longtemps sur cette émission du
cuivre de manière de laisser un message
et les indices s'accumulent en plus des
précisions données dans le rouleau de
cuivre ainsi la cité de chorale est la
copie conforme du temple de jérusalem
chorale se situe aussi sur ligne droite
est à équidistance entre jérusalem le
monde est beau ou fut enterré moïse
[Musique]
from the question le texte du rouleau de
cuivre parle d'un endroit où se trouve
un cimetière
or à cobra il y à un cimetière
[Musique]
c'est donc à combrailles près du
cimetière qu'il faut diriger les
fouilles pour savoir où creuser nos
chercheurs de trésor vont devoir
utiliser des méthodes encore inconnu
dans le monde de l'archéologie au sein
du couple franco allemand
le pacific dawn
et pour la première fois une étude
sismique est effectué dans le domaine de
l'archéologie et malgré les critiques
des archéologues qui ne croient pas en
son efficacité
le sismique repérera deux anomalies sous
le sol de couronne à ixelles inexactes
nouveau drop de serre mais trop c'est
trop
mais qu'est ce
il y a donc quelque chose sous le sol de
qumrân et maintenant que l'on sait où
chercher
la véritable fouilles va pouvoir
commencer mais l'autorité des antiquités
et des parcs d'israël n'octroie à gary
cole est l'autorisation de creuser sur
le plateau de qumran que durant cinq
semaines
passé ce délai gary devra impérativement
reboucher le trou
à moins d'avoir découvert la chambre
secrète une course contre la montre est
donc entamé et pour réussir cette
opération
gary cole être ni autour de lui une
équipe internationale
on y trouve le chercheur aubry
richardson l'archéologue américain
randall price qui a déjà publié un livre
sur les rouleaux de la mer morte et qui
dirigera les recherches
l'archéologue l'israélien oren gutfeld
de l'université hébraïque de jérusalem
qui a déjà participé à d'autres
excavation sur le site de combrailles
l'archéologue d'israéliens il ya accord
kalman qui se chargera du travail
technique des excavations le géologue
irlandais jim higgins qui analysera les
données géophysiques et enfin l'avocat
franco israélien michel calvo qui
seconde ragga recall est dans la
direction de l'expédition et se chargera
des permis ainsi que des liens avec
l'administration
il devra bien sûr aussi s'occuper de
l'aspect juridique des trouvailles
[Musique]
qui est aussi une vingtaine de
volontaires tout spécialement venu des
états unis et de france pour participer
à l'aventuré dans cette équipe
internationale
les chrétiens pratiquants des
évangélistes travaille de concert avec
des juifs pour retrouver les trésors du
temple de jérusalem
les grands rabbins goren et bakshi de
rolle encourage les fouilles le
kabbaliste david cohen suit l'évolution
des recherches et fait part de ses
connaissances pour guider l'équipe et
jean-marc rozenfeld de l'institut du
temple aide pour l'identification des
trouvailles
[Musique]
et jean ferrat méthodes pas très
face à être offert à l'achat et couvrir
mai
penalty mais robert a été attribué g
cham et l l'homme est clos brochet
folâtre il ben shushan un flag et alstom
chasse aux amateurs de marche et la
course mikko balle banjo
[Musique]
le
sa fin
[Musique]
passée l'euphorie du premier jour la
difficulté de la tâche se fait sentir
tandis que se multiplient les embûches
de nous s'ils maintiennent en somme
[Musique]
exacte
et c'est jean qui va régler le problème
en se servant de ses propres logiciels
informatiques
il va comparer les mesures actuelles du
plateau avec celle d'il ya dix ans et
c'est ainsi que une par une
il va retrouver les marques qui avait
été fait lors des précédents forage mais
surtout il va retrouver l'embouchure du
tuyau que salomone avait enfoncé dans le
sol
le fameux tuyaux qui servira de fil
d'ariane jusqu'à la chambre cacher c'est
le long de ce tuyau que les archéologues
devront creuser
afin d'atteindre la chambre cacher et de
trouver le deuxième rouleaux de cuivre
clé donnant accès au trésor du temple
[Musique]
ça fait
ls
60e gaudin
la fouille peut maintenant démarrer
ya'acov kalman prévoit de creuser un
maître par jour à ce rythme si tout va
bien d'ici 15 jours
il devrait atteindre la chambre cacher
si dans vos recherches et vous trouverez
des choses qui paraissent elles des
objets du temps bien sûr faut faire
faudra faire très attention de ne pas y
toucher
et d'appeler juste je me plais à moi je
me prévenir des gens qui sont allés d'un
emprunt a promis que v car tout ce
qu'elle est dans l'eau dans le temps
adapté particulière et donc il faut pas
s'amuser avec cela parce que dieu
préserve quand c'est pas respecté à
s'inquiéter des choses ça peut faire du
match très important face ya trois ans
ce que je voulais vous rappeler pourquoi
t-il de ma colère j'espère vous
trouverez baisse rattachement
[Musique]
c'est le remboursement
je
à
[Musique]
le
quatrième jour depuis hier l'équipe
s'occupant de la première anomalie celle
signalée à moins de trois mètres semble
approcher de quelque chose
[Musique]
rencontre
en france
[Musique]
ce sont deux choses
mais la découverte de la cuisine a eu un
effet des tonneaux sur l'équipe
non seulement c'est une trouvaille
archéologique mais en plus elle accorde
du crédit aux résultats de la recherche
sismique
celle ci avait révélé l'existence d'une
anomalie précision qui s'est avérée
exacte avec la cuisine tout ceci est
très encourageant est très prometteur
pour la deuxième anomalie celle située à
15 mètres sous terre et qui d'après tous
les espoirs devrait correspondre à la
chambre cacher ou devrait se situer le
deuxième rouleaux de cuivre
désormais toute l'énergie est focalisée
sur le trou d'autant plus que le temps
avance plus vite que prévu et que les
travaux deviennent plus dur
au fur et à mesure que l'équipe
s'enfonce dans le sol
[Musique]
août
il
qui
[Musique]
pour
tous
et
[Musique]
je
king
[Musique]
les fouilles commencées à 4 heures du
matin mais se termine à une heure de
l'après midi car après il fait trop
chaud pour travailler
l'équipe peut alors se détendre au
kibboutz kalia où elle a pris ses
quartiers
elle peut aussi plongé dans sa piscine
prendre des bains de boue et flotter
dans la mer morte
[Applaudissements]
elle pose se rafraîchir du côté de aïn
gaydier de ces chutes
car après tout les volontaires sont
aussi en vacances
[Musique]
27e jour de forage l'équipe n'est plus
qu'à 1 mètres de l'endroit où est censé
se trouver la chambre cacher elle
devrait l'atteindre aujourd'hui
gary cole est à renvoyer la main
d'oeuvre
il ne reste plus sur le site que
l'équipe minimale
les membres officiels de l'association
et quelques volontaires venus d'amérique
pour participer au projet aujourd'hui
sera peut être le dernier jour le grand
jour celui que tout le monde attend
depuis près de dix ans et d'autres
depuis 2000 ans
des trésors du temple ne sont pas
trésor des pirates puisque c'est trésor
sans hautement spirituelle et nous
cherchons absolument à identifier chaque
chose lui l'onction entre autres les
parfums les objets qui sont là avait une
hauteur de spiritualité qui permettait
un rapprochement vers dieu 1
[Musique]
je
m
la global ou
[Musique]
ja
où
m
[Musique]
moi
nous sommes heureux de mettre à peu près
de m même sentiment chez rim cm
paris
[Musique]
gaza
le bout du forage est atteint et avec
lui le lieu présumé de la chambre cacher
mais en fait il n'y a pas de salle n'est
de cavités rien seulement de la pierre
de la terre dans lesquels il faut encore
creusé et après la déception première
les membres de l'équipe sont maintenant
gagner par le doute
[Musique]
poser exactement à la façon dont on fait
un escalier
et l'échelle a été exactement il y à une
échelle si une échelle de l'autre côté
et en faisant cela on n'a pas pu suivre
on n'a pas pu suivre le trou qui a été
fait par salomone veut dire qu'en fait
ils sont partis du belon droit mais ils
ont continué mon endroit on a continué
de creuser parce qu'on s'est focalisé
sur le trou que carrick colette avait
fait auparavant
pour cela nous sommes en irak a atteint
à cette distance mais en ce qui concerne
en ce qui concerne le l'autre trophée
par un salomon indien là il est
peut-être il est peut-être cacher
voudrait dire en fait ils sont partis du
baulois les parties roi mais ils sont
partis à gauche au lieu d'aller à droite
x factor voilà intéressant n'est-ce pas
on peut être passé à côté d'une
découverte colossale à cause de nos
instincts et à cause d'un manque de
précision technique scientifique
alors maintenant ce qu'on va faire
j'espère on va essayer de voir où se
trouvent ces 15 mai 30 et 17 mai 30
halle travers le tube de deux salles aux
banques de salomone et voir exactement
ce qu'il en est
ou alors si en creux en faisant cela on
n'arrive pas à atteindre cette qualité
et bien ça voudra dire que c'est tous
plantés et en ce qui me concerne ça fait
neuf ans je travaille dessus
voilà
alors aux mesures et les chiffres sont
bons mais alors où est la cavité il
semblerait que la théorie de michel
calvo soit exact en creuse en colimaçon
l'équipe se serait éloigné du point
recherché le trou est certes à la bonne
profondeur mais plus dans la bonne
direction
il va donc falloir essayer de rejoindre
le bout du tube de salomone là où est
censé se trouver la salle tant recherché
est la seule façon d'y arriver est de
creuser un tunnel tâches ingrates qui
tombe sur ya'acov qui devra creuser
creuser
mais dans quelle direction et sur
combien de m
des pneus
[Musique]
les fouilles touchent à leur fin
le budget aussi il ne permettra de
financer les recherches radars et
sismique que pour une seule journée
alors qu'il en faudrait plusieurs
il va donc falloir faire des concessions
à les eaux plus sûres
et c'est là qu'apparaissent les
premières dissensions dans l'équipe
[Musique]
on a été
granby
120e
la collecte des 21 mai
j'ai pigé
à
oui
[Musique]
le radar passé en surface du plateau de
cobral ne révélera rien de particulier
ni cavité ni crevasses grotte rien à ce
niveau les géologues prennent alors la
liberté d'élargir la recherche mais en
vain est ce parce que les conditions du
terrain ne sont pas assez bonnes comme
ils le disent est ce parce que leurs
équipements et leurs technologies ne
sont pas aussi performants qu'ils le
prétendent ou est ce tout simplement
parce qu'il n'y a rien dans le sous sol
du plateau de qumrân pour en avoir le
coeur net
alex bec et son équipe de géologues vont
devoir descendre dans le puits avec tout
leur équipement afin de poursuivre leurs
recherches depuis l'intérieur de la
montagne
[Musique]
tout m'énervait des autres commence par
cher clown et en azote d'argent si tu le
reconnais qu'il est bonne celle là on
peut présumer nigeria le biais les
matches affichent des quiches relatives
aux enchères au sim ce qui rime radar
des cris des pleurs des internautes y
ait des bagadoù même médium celle à
venir aux vins maçonnique la capitale en
vo quy retailleau gamme ambulatory mais
l'entrepreneur gran afghane dont huit
années à la gaine réagi à ces chiens
d'attaqué quoi la retraite il a cédé un
iota raymone bain j'imaginais m le
paillage clichy vous allez recevoir la
soupe chez la femme à la barre
je crée pas de cliché n'est pas évident
alors que la chaîne se mettre un prix
nobel à louviers les échos marché un
radis rothschild et mes lectures dollars
chez lolita et à la capelle madame eva
lechner josh amateurs mais mes classes
mais a déclaré m
sarko l'anneau de leur dette totale d'un
au bout du môle 1 où l'air est bonne
étoile et année et le mot tu lâches et
les copains mais le rate
[Musique]
là encore le radar ne trouvera rien
là haut
en surface les fourrés poterie
découvertes sont exposées pour la
dernière fois dans leur lieu d'origine
ils vont être transportés vers
l'université hébraïque de jérusalem
puisque les radars ne sont pas assez
puissants le seul moyen de retrouver la
cavité et dorée effectué une recherche
sismique
exactement comme celles qui avaient été
faites quelques années auparavant par
l'université de tel aviv le sismique est
une technologie très précises pour en
explorer le sol jusqu'à de très grandes
profondeurs
mais cela coûte très cher et surtout
contrairement aux radars qui donne des
résultats immédiatement le sismique
nécessite un délai de plusieurs jours
avant de pouvoir rendre les informations
ce qui s'y est un problème car nous
sommes à moins d'une semaine de la
limite accordée pour les fouilles et
notre équipe va devoir repartir en
guerre contre l'administration afin
d'obtenir de toute urgence une rallonge
de deux semaines pour trouver le trésor
qui semble lui échapper mais il n'y a
rien à faire
l'autorité des parcs d'israël reste de
glace et n'accordera pas une journée de
plus il n'ya plus qu'à souhaiter que les
résultats du sismique arrive rapidement
mais le mauvais sort semble s'acharner
contre notre équipe car aussi incroyable
que cela puisse paraître l'ordinateur
des géologues analysant les résultats de
l'étude sismique a planté et avec lui
ont été effacées toutes les informations
qu'il contenait quatre jours de perdus
alex bec et son équipe n'ont plus qu'à
recommencer logiquement il est déjà trop
tard
les résultats d'une nouvelle étude
sismique ne pourrons arriver avant la
date butoir
tant pis on tente quand même qui s'est
entre temps il ya un coffre kalman
déploie un dernier effort en creusant un
deuxième tunnel allant dans une autre
direction peut-être la bonne cette fois
ci les membres de l'institut de
géophysique d'israël en profite alors
pour faire une nouvelle recherche un
radar avec cette fois un matériel plus
adapté
c'est l'essai de la dernière chance
celui qui couronnera ou non tous les
efforts déployés galerie colette randall
price michel calvo et tous les autres
sont fixés sur les géologues les seconds
semble durer une éternité
les gestes prennent des heures et la
tante des résultats du radar qui doivent
pourtant apparaître en direct prend des
allures d'accouchement
[Musique]
je
les bras d'arias congrès qui comme à
chaque abonné matraques de l'heure
van hummel m koné
venez chez nous
golog les fromages ou tac d'honneur
celle terrasses étaient à bord les
remarques venez rire
raymond thomas
[Musique]
samedi 2 0
tout cela nous démontre que le radar
n'est pas quelque chose de très efficace
en soi
mais ne détecte que des différences
éventuellement de pierre avec cela nous
nous sentions nous sommes bien avancés
bravo la technique
je suis certes important qui doit
exister un tas d'autres matériels
puisqu'il
et
utiliser
par l'armée pour déterminer s'il existe
des tunnels qui passent sous la
frontière
aussi bien dans le nord que du côté de
gaza et en egypte
[Musique]
tout cela est bien triste sapho cela
fait bien neuf ans que je travaille sur
ce projet avec désespoir
les difficultés des suppositions
[Musique]
j'ai appris pas mal de choses sur la
science sur la technique
en ce qui concerne les infrarouges par
exemple je me rappelle que la personne
était optimiste possible en voyant juste
en bas de la zone ombragée des
indications prouvant qu'il y avait une
qualité
ensuite il y a eu les forages
[Musique]
on
on ne saura jamais ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que salomone s'est trompé
peut-être qu'il a fait une simple erreur
de manipulation dont il croyait qu'il y
a il avait trouvé la cavité
son tube se seraient enfoncés là où il a
déjà où ils avaient déjà pénétré
[Musique]
et maintenant
après neuf ans on a creusé un trou je
trouve de mes rêves avec des tunnels
dans tous les sens
[Musique]
et on n'a rien trouvé
j'ai l'impression d'avoir vécu dans le
rêve comme gary cole est
comme ce trajet
comme ce sont tous ces gens aux états
unis fo a aidé à financer ce projet
depuis plus de dix ans
[Musique]
ça aurait pu ça aurait pu être une très
belle histoire
[Musique]
et maintenant
maintenant que les fouilles n'ont rien
donné et que les radars ont confondu une
pierre avec du vide
il ne reste plus qu à reboucher le trou
et il faut le reboucher maintenant alors
que les résultats de l'étude sismique ne
sont pas encore arrivés car la date
limite de l'autorisation accordée par
l'autorité des antiquités est atteinte
et que le parc de combraille attend des
visiteurs
et en quelques heures de travail
le bulldozer va enterrer un mois et demi
d'efforts et dix ans de rêve
[Musique]
deux jours après avoir comblé le trou
les résultats d'une étude sismique
révéleront l'existence d'une cavité de
trois mètres sur trois est situé
seulement à 1 mètre 50 du trou que gary
colette et michel calvo viennent de
reboucher
[Musique]
il faudra donc creuser de nouveau ce qui
semble désormais impossible car
l'autorité des antiquités et des parcs
d'israël s'opposent depuis au forage de
tout nouveaux trous sur le plateau de
combraille de peur de voir celui-ci
s'écrouler et le trésor du temple enfoui
quelque part au pied de moitié qui parle
retourne dans l'ombre attendant toujours
d'être découvert
[Musique]
on
bon
[Musique]